[Music]
in nope news nope submitted by Lana
backward [ __ ] my ear drew what did you
even click down on his ring our marriage
your marriage that's how strong it is
I can't even shatter glass well this
glass you still contain pros what the
[ __ ] Joe what's going on I'm [ __ ]
promoting barbells I thought he was mad
at us like he's in seventh grade giving
of you can't see the logo from the front
so that's why I'm giving you guys a ball
turn the shirt the other way and then
you could tell the front design thank
you and love drew myself on a napkin for
you absolutely didn't know about it's
like the Kikkoman soy sauce thing what
that was hell Asian you come on soy
sauce yeah oh that's funny that's a dope
logo I know it's a joke design it's
pretty nice
thank you my Lana backwards that's anal
got tricked a deep-sea fishermen shares
his craziest discoveries on social media
oh hold on y'all know how [ __ ] up the
deep-sea oh yeah deep sea is terrifying
but like I remember there was an entire
what's that what's that show that
everyone likes you real high and watch
planet Earth planet Earth yeah there's a
lot of all the ones you could someone
was high when they're watching it what
did it mean it yeah planet Mars planet
Earth whatever yeah planet Earth -
there's a whole deep-sea episode now I
remember I was hyped on this but it
doesn't really show [ __ ] you know me and
s we got stoned and we watched that [ __ ]
she was so scared so the animals just
like let's watch the space stuff and I
was like okay is that less care about
deep-sea is you guys stop
you guys are [ __ ] high school watch
the space stuff okay okay because we
were watching the deep sea [ __ ] and she
didn't like the the anglerfish just
you're like but then you put the
flashlight on that [ __ ] there is
a hell on earth and it's in the deep sea
and that's what you become if you [ __ ]
up in life you have feelings too like
there's different you haven't even we've
never hit the bottom layer I know all
about the deep sea that's my jam when
everyone's trying to go into space I'm
like hell no I want to go down there
yeah I think that they're so scared that
they're like nevermind let's go back up
let's go up because the deep sea is
terrifying
sorry David that's a jack Cousteau ass
[ __ ] this fisherman his name is Roman
Roman I only want to go ten feet deep
that's it because then my ears start
hurting oh I can teach you how to get
rid of that I learn how to equalize he's
from Russia I learn how to equal that
goes deep sea diving in Norway oh that's
too cold oh my god those dragons are
disguised as fish she looks like a drag
oh my god that's wild looking why did he
bring it up leave it alone oh he brings
up all his discovery so he's sure
catfish
Oh Cheshire cat wow that is crazy
looking so ugly I think I might eat that
that's scary
well it looks like s teeth but it's just
flat Oh get the squid that's a squid I
thought was a starfish hey that [ __ ]
looks like a baby trapped in a [ __ ]
starfish oh yeah it does it looks like
it's going like The Annoying Orange
mouth yeah
I wish I could see this stuff at the zoo
I'll be tight yeah this other one what
the lot
what's it got a collar eyes the dogs
didn't recall see edition Hellboy fish
boy I've seen that one Oh like a cartoon
dragon no photos that's got to be a
really like a deep deep down in there
cuz I think the eyes are like that so he
can see yeah this one what the [ __ ] is a
straight-up penis is that a dick it
looks like I look like a dick and a
vagina it looks like a parasite that
they would use like in the Alien movie
yeah it's supposed to climb into your
bellybutton and [ __ ] you up that's the
one why are they even there inside of a
vagina change it I'm getting two out of
two you it's a limp dick coming out of a
vagina dude you know I have a major
problem with to this texture that's just
not it's not on anything it's not it is
so good it doesn't make you salivate
elevate because I know what that tastes
like the texture of fish look like
yellowtail collar right here yeah it
does
and I wish I knew what it looked like in
its natural habits I like how it swam
you guys know that you the geoduck thing
yeah they're like Chinese market where
the shells like this big but like all
the inside comes all the way out yeah
because in deep sea there's a lot of
pressure so that pressure contains all
that meat so these guys are on the
surface now so deep deep deep down there
where there's like tons of pressure what
does that fish look like down there now
that fish might not even be that big it
might be squish like this small but it's
because we brought it up and it expanded
now looks like that gooey duck so I
wonder what it look like
in its original habitat they're
interesting though they're also taking
photos in the weirdest angles too it's
kind of like that sand shark or whatever
if you take it from the belly angle it
looks like a hurt
yeah aurélien area ya know cuz uh what
was a Barnum & Bailey they used that yes
and indeed these they traveled around
with it saying it's something I made
yeah I don't know that this way looking
as teeth that fool just looks like a
British guy oh my gosh been in the Sun
for too long like like one of those a
political British cartoons actual human
being for those UK cartoon that looks so
crazy Sherlock Holmes drawing yes it
looks like it has some [ __ ] slimy
skin just looks like a really old UK
lady just looks like a monster this is
what you reincarnate up to talk to
cheese cheese to NY when you're nice
mother tongue ugly ass finishing town I
wonder if they taste good probably not
or maybe maybe they're angler fish in
the Tsukiji Japanese fish market wow
that's some deep [ __ ] no she was always
it was like all flat it looks like jello
it's all flattened out and weird-looking
they were selling English fish people
are really interesting looking though
scared holy why these deep-sea fish have
like the biggest fungus like look like a
pecker Paku Paku fish they're known to
actually crush dues nut sacs on accident
because they'll be in the water they eat
nuts like actual hard nuts and so
there's been stories where guys have
been in the water and they [ __ ] fish
is crushed their testicles
that looks like the parrot fish in
Hawaii this fool got four-way teeth no
man it looks like an alien
he's got the teeth that the mask [ __ ]
has oh yeah okay what if these things
are the aliens and they come into the
water instead of like roaming there
they're pretty dumb band
yeah we're catching them like nothing I
mean the fact that we can't yes
we did this who could travel through
space but he just ends up in the water
[ __ ] up other aliens that's all they
do can time travel and you'll never know
well that was pointless and useless cuz
he's not even getting to experience what
human life is like you're just stuck in
a deep sea maybe the real [ __ ] is in the
ocean like what like gambling nonsense
oh you mean like a alien City food yes
is it if they're underground entities
that we haven't heard of are those
aliens because they are inhabitants of
Planet they've been here for a while and
we haven't seen each other yet what have
they been trying to get up to where we
are for like years of space like this
guy was almost done we just ended his
ass I'm scared of the deep-sea dog
because it is very real I want to see a
big squid no it's very literally real
giant squid so sperm whales with the
[ __ ] huge suction cups on yeah yeah
cuz we got [ __ ] up by the giant squid
yeah that's just real dude oh my god
that's so see everyone looks like a frog
or a frog
go get go or something as I'm like a
gecko and I know yeah that color
this guy's jobs gotta be so exciting
though that he just goes out there and
he's like let's see what weird [ __ ]
we're gonna catch today and like you
know in life there's no limitation to
the weirdness that per month - yeah out
there where like in the water or like
wherever you deep-sea like he's Miley's
peeping on the boat was he shut up he's
a deep-sea fishermen if he pulled it up
from a net or whatever oh it's all stuck
in there oh that thing I've seen that
before I've seen that that's actually a
shark that they thought it soon was
extinct yeah not the coast of Japan hmm
all the seafoods supposed to be gone in
24 days about this one maybe it's just a
cool squid where's the gun it's gonna be
over fished and the ecosystems gonna be
destroyed by 2044
that soon because of everything like
overfishing the plastics everything put
together I got 20 years to eat crab legs
well it's like you know how it works
right like if you take a few that's like
the predator
we know when the part opens its mouth
inside of a turtle Oh mom deep sea
turtles a sort of turtle yeah she looks
like tremors remember that movie I've
heard where you're like little snakes in
the water and like yeah tremors those
are real I don't like that why are we
wired to be grossed out by these geysers
but there's probably a reason
oh dude you were wired to be afraid of
the unknown did you know that seat right
there ugly yeah it was aren't endangered
anymore oh they're not they're not on
the endangered species anymore because
of all the like the efforts to reach so
we could touch them now no you still
can't Oh
and so now there's an issue of like too
many of these sea turtles so if you've
noticed like in Hawaii what they said is
there's been a lot more shark attacks
the reason why is because their foods
back the turtle sea turtles Oh
still can hunt it but they're thinking
about it no turtle were their food yeah
so like these huge sharks so they're
trying to do this thing right now we're
local if they have like like in Kauai or
something like that it because
traditionally they did eat sea turtles
yeah there are gonna allow them to like
hunt for one a year depending on if you
have like that blood or lineage but
that's so cute dog I mean when we go to
how many [ __ ] sea trails do we see a
lot a lot yeah for an endangered species
you know I mean yeah I saw yeah I saw
like twelve and one Lagoon exactly thank
you yeah baby ones there's mom ones and
then sometimes the baby ones will float
around and then just chill with you yeah
yeah and then they swim like yeah I got
no care in the world
yeah and a very like slow motion oh very
tranquil
[Music]